-Congratulations, hosted "SNL."
Fantastic.
-Yeah, that was awesome.
-Second time back.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Needless to say, I was thrilled
to see Stefon again.
-Yes, Stefon did come back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And, uh...
-That's John Mulaney.
-Yep.
-John Mulaney writes Stefon
and is our dear friend.
And he came out
as Stefon's lawyer, Shy.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
He was a lawyer as well as a --
-As a conceptual piss artist.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And he whispered in my ear
to make me laugh.
He said, "My girlfriend" --
[ Laughing ]
[ Laughter ]
He goes, "My girlfriend works at
Yoshinoya Beef Bowl."
[ Laughter ]
Which is a restaurant chain
in L.A.
[ Laughter ]
-I will say it's very --
You mentioned --
I got a nice mention.
Thank you so much.
-Yes, yes.
I did "A Closer Look."
Stefon, your husband,
did "A Closer Look."
-And it is --
It's the question
I get asked the most is,
"How's Stefon?"
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughing ]
-So I was very happy to be --
Like, it's a weird thing,
'cause I'm --
I just want you to know,
I'm fully aware that Stefon
is a fictional character.
-Oh, sure.
-But when he's with other men,
I have a real, like,
"I'm glad he's happy."
-Yeah, right, right, right.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, Colin."
-Oh, good -- Colin.
-"I love it -- Colin.
Oh, that's interesting."
-Oh, good.
Little young for you, Stefon.
-Little young, Colin.
Oh, yeah.
"Little young. Going young.
I see how it is."
-But I'm happy for you, Stefon.
-I'm doing well, too.
[ Laughter ]
-But I want to ask --
Wait, I want to show a clip.
You played an old man.
What was your name in the scene?
-Oh, Horace!
-Horace.
He -- He, uh...
-Yeah.
-So that was a sketch
that Cecily Strong
and James Anderson wrote.
And it just said,
"Bill enters in a wheelchair."
And I was like,
"Well, that's getting picked."
-Yeah.
-"We're gonna do that."
And it's very dirty.
-You had taken some Cialis.
-And she wants to get pregnant.
-Yeah.
-And so --
[ Laughter ]
We're a couple,
and my Cialis kicked in,
and it only lasts
for a couple minutes,
so they had
to take the opportunity
to try to get pregnant.
[ Laughter ]
-I was so impressed,
because I know from
having worked there
and just network censors,
clearly, the rules are you're
not allowed to simulate at all.
-Anything!
-Yeah.
-And Betsy, very nice lady,
came down and said,
"Bill, you are not allowed
to move a muscle
when she sits down on you."
-Yeah.
-"Or we're gonna be -- you know,
we're gonna get in trouble.
But, you know, it was fun.
-But what you could move
was the wheelchair.
-I could move the --
-And you were really --
[ Laughter ]
You were really good at it.
And I want to show --
[ Laughter ]
This is, uh --
You were great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It was so bad.
Poor Melissa.
Oh, yeah.
Do you have a clip of it?
-Oh, yeah.
Let's take a look.
-I guess we will leave.
Come on, Horace.
Wow.
Slow...
Slow.
Horace.
-Know what? No.
You know what?
You should be ashamed
of yourselves.
This woman is --
[ Laughing ]
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
This woman is your friend.
-You, uh --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm so bad at my job.
-You got very, um --
I was watching that, I'm like,
"Oh, God, Bill got very good
over the years of knowing where
to put his face when he breaks."
-Yeah, I had to go
right behind her, yeah.
Well, it was bad 'cause I backed
up and I knew I hit something,
but I didn't know what it was.
And I could hear Melissa
behind me going, "It's me."
[ Laughter ]
Just like, "Oh, it's me."
And I look,
and I see Aidy Bryant,
so I'm like,
"Well, if Aidy's alone,
that means I have
the entire table behind me."
[ Laughter ]
And she's looking at me
like this, and I'm just like --
-It was -- You always --
[ Laughter ]
There's such little space
to operate anything
in an "SNL" sketch.
-Oh, no, it's awful.
-And it reminded me
another sketch you were in,
which was a game-show sketch
where Wiig and Maya were like
showcase show girls
in a golf cart.
-Yes, yes.
-And I think Maya
was driving around a golf cart
in just a tiny circle,
and Wiig had to run around her
being like, "Wait! Hold on!"
[ Laughter ]
-And then it cut to me
and Vanessa Bayer.
That was the sketch
that started -- I'm sorry.
that started, um --
-Oh, yeah,
it was a game-show sketch
with the best opening line.
-The best opening line was --
So it was like,
"You -- We -- You said --
Now we're back from the break.
The answer you gave was "beef."
I'm so sorry, but the correct
answer was "nine."
[ Laughter ]
Which means that she said,
"I believe the answer is beef,"
and they went,
"We'll see if you're correct
right after this message."
[ Laughter ]
And I read that --
James Anderson, again, wrote it.
And when that came up,
we all started laughing.
-It was great.
Well, you crushed it, buddy.
-Thank you, buddy.
-And congrats on "Barry."
Can't wait to see more of it.
-Awesome.
-Bill Hader, everybody.